have you ever wondered how strong a
character is when the universe Survival
tournament was revealed so too came the
announcement of universe sevens squad
like any Dragon Ball fan at the time I
went to my head and organized the team
from weakest to strongest using what I
knew about the series but it got me
thinking I wonder if there exists a way
to figure out their actual power levels
and I don't mean like typical fan
assumptions based on nothing no I'm
talking more about using the original
source material interviews with Akira
Toriyama and extrapolating what we can
from that to piece together the most
accurate power level reading for each
individual fighter in universe sevens
team
honestly this sounded like fun and I'm
always up for a challenge so today I
present to you the first episode in a
show that I am now calling the power
levels series in which I will break down
each character in the universe 7 lineup
beginning with the weakest ultimately
ending with the most powerful hopefully
finding it along the way with each
individual character what their power
level actually is I'm totally not Marc
and this is the power of series episode
1 Master Roshi
[Music]
Master Roshi is a human-type earthly 350
years old his techniques include the
maava otherwise known as the Evo
containment wave the afterimage
technique Thunder shock surprise and he
is the originator of the Kamehameha it
becomes known to us very early on in the
series that Master Roshi is widely
considered the best martial artist on
the planet performing feats a power that
quite frankly couldn't be topped for
quite a while in the series acting as
the mentor and master - the series
protagonist Goku for a considerable
amount of time but what exactly is Roshi
capable of well early on in the series
comes an instance that shows us just how
powerful he can be in which Master Roshi
uses his full power form to unleash his
signature ki attack towards the moon
erasing it from the sky pretty
impressive for a guy in his 300s but
this specifically is interesting because
it tells us something about Master Roshi
as a character once he meets Goku he
becomes very focused on cultivating the
next generation always wanting to
evaluate and encourage younger fighters
like Goku Crillon and tension hun to
better themselves and always prepare for
someone stronger which are still words
that echoing Goku is mine today and even
though he participated in tournaments
against the likes of Goku Crillon and
tension on Roshi
never once used that form against them
specifically using it only a handful of
times in the entire series when the
situation deemed it crucial so with that
in mind let's talk numbers Master Roshi
as we currently know him today has three
states or forms for lack of a better
term the first one being his base form
in this state he might seem like a
fragile old man but even in this form he
is capable of superhuman feats like
catching bullets with his bare hands the
rats I got brought many new great
additions to the series like Goku being
an alien and having a brother but more
importantly for this video it introduced
power levels to the series once Raddatz
is taken care of embattled bulla
remodels his scudder and uses it to read
Master Roshi's power level in his base
form it reads 139 and given that the
average human power level is around a 5
that's incredible for an Earthling
moving swiftly along the next state of
powerful Roshi doesn't exactly have a
name but it's tapped into when he begins
taking things a bit more seriously
can see this Foreman action during his
fight with tension huh during the King
Piccolo saga weekly jump issue number 31
clocks Master Roshi's power level at 180
who went in this form what might be
worth noting also is that during his
match with tension on Master Roshi's
main focus is on training and mentoring
him guiding him away from the corrupt
crane school voluntarily jumping out of
the ring forfeiting the fight the final
and most powerful transformation for
Roshi however is his full power state
where there's a dramatic increase in
muscle mass with seemingly no drawback
in speed in this state he can manipulate
and use his key attacks at maximum power
one of the only drawbacks to this form
is its stamina consumption it's just not
built to last
some examples include destroying Fire
Mountain blowing up the moon and more
recently fighting freezes army in
resurrection if that said unfortunately
there is no official power reading for
this form there is however a way to
figure it out or at the very least get
as close as I possibly can in Dragon
Ball super as listed earlier Roshi
participated in the battle against
freezes army in the resurrection of F
Ark in this section of the show Master
Roshi stands alongside the other Z
warriors as they face 170 Frieza
soldiers each so using freezes army as a
reference point it's time for some good
old-fashioned mental gymnastics let's
see if we can't get some good ol logic
going so the first thing that we need to
do is we need to figure out the average
strength of a freezer force soldier now
the official power levels are given for
characters like dodoria Saban and Kui
but these are referencing freezes elite
members and are the best of the best
within the freeze of force definitely
not common foot soldiers but thankfully
in Dyson qu 7 there is reference to
these two gentlemen banana and Tsui who
both have power levels of 1,500
according to Dyson sure these guys seem
to be a good example for grunts and
freezes army now that we have this
average to go off of let's look at
something Frieza said I cannot believe
how weak my army has grown they can't
even take out that little piece of scrap
referencing Crillon this however I think
is to be taken with a pinch of salt we
all know Frieza can sense power levels
and therefore I think this is a
throwaway statement highlighting his
disappointment for his Army's
shortcomings right so I think we can
safely assume that the Frieza force is
somewhere in the region of one to two
thousand in terms of power level and I
think that's a fair assumption given
what we have to work with moving along
taking a look at this quote from the
Android saga as a teen is fighting
Vegeta the other Z warriors arrived on
the scene 17 points out that even a teen
won't be able to take them all on if
they jump in at once in this situation
18 was a decent bit stronger than Vegeta
trunks would be second in strength and
piccolo following 3rd adding in Crillon
intention on that brings the total to 5
Z warriors 2 of which are relatively
close to 18th strength and when I say
relatively I mean 18 isn't like twice as
strong as them using Gohan versus the
cell juniors as an example wherein one
fighter was taking on multiple opponents
we can infer that one must be 2.5 times
stronger when dealing with more than two
opponents easily at least this is also
observed when Goku is facing Jason Bert
on nanoq during the fight with the
Frieza soldiers Roshi manages the Horde
really well fighting only a few soldiers
at a given time slowing down only when
his stamina gave up so Gavin what we've
learned about crowd control and Dragon
Ball we can say that in order to handle
170 soldiers as competently as he did
sometimes dealing with three or more at
a given time he would need to be at
least two to three times their level
heck he even takes the time to mentor
Crillon halfway through his fight taking
all of this into account Master Roshi
has to have a power level of at least
three thousand seven hundred and fifty
assuming of course that the [ __ ] has a
power level of 1500 now any season
Dragon Ball fan will tell you that
relying on an individual's power level
alone will result in a losing effort in
the blink of an eye Roshi could harness
his ki into a single kamehameha causing
the blast to be many times stronger than
Roshi's current level similar to when
piccolo charges special beam cannon
against Raddatz or Goku super kamehameha
against piccolo both of these were much
more powerful than the user's current
level in both cases each character
roughly tripled their respective power
outputs this means that if Roshi chars
are super Kamehameha assuming he's
capable of such could produce a blast
with a power level reading off 11250 but
that's just speculation based on what
Goku's done in the past so with all that
said Roshi's power level is at least
three thousand seven hundred fifty when
he's as max
and honestly he could very well be more
than this so what could have caused this
well it has been about 20 years after
the events of Dragonball Roshi is a
martial artist by nature and come on how
many times have you heard Chris a he's
gone off the trainer oh she's the man is
a martial arts genius packed with more
tricks than he can count hundreds of
years of experience and in modern-day
Dragon Ball super is feeling greater
than he has ever felt thanks to the
Paradise planned everyone should get
excited because Roshi is coming out of
retirement to help save the earth once
again now before I bring this video to a
close I would personally like to send a
huge thank you to Herms and the team
over at Kaizen chu for creating the
Dragon Balls strength checker the people
that were involved literally went
through the entire manga and made
accurate translations from Japanese to
English for every instance strengths
became a topic of conversation
it honestly proved invaluable when
writing this series I'll leave a link if
you want to check it out in the
description down below now if you guys
want to see me tackle the next strongest
fighter in the universe seven team
because honestly it gets way more
detailed than this don't forget to leave
a like if you enjoyed this video
subscribe if you want to see other
videos like this did you guys think I
hit the nail on the head or did you
think that I was way off let me know in
the comment section down below and as
always I've been totally not mark thank
you so much for watching are you still
there oh you're still there don't really
know what else to say I don't really
have anything written down yes probably
get to work in the next episode let's go
take about 20 years to make a three eyed
freaks gonna be hired alright see you
guys
you